[Music]
[Music]
i got some troubles but they won't last
i'm gonna lay
right down here in the grass
and pretty soon all my troubles will
pass cause i miss you she
should should
[Music]
sugar town
[Music]
[Music]
hello are you still in bed
no i've been up for a while
yesterday it rained in tennessee
i heard it all surrendered
[Music]
[Music]
sure
we brought you some groceries thanks
jesus
i know it's not me
so what's new
your uh mom's biopsy came back by nine
really cool
you should go get your moles checked out
too
yeah definitely
are your finances they're okay
credit card could be worse you know
we're not bailing you out again
i had a big case last week really what
was it
you know i'm not supposed to talk about
that stuff
this gay guy wanted me to find out
whether another guy was gay
was he yeah a little bit
oh that's nice
should i be worried if my pee smells
like fish
yeah maybe you know vary beans is in the
back right
so what
just leave man we're not gonna judge you
i used to be loved
i used to be a kid detective
when i was 13 i saw the case of the
missing fundraiser money
it was rory beans the neighborhood
knucklehead
in the beginning i ran my trade out of a
tree house
somebody saw the basketball magazines
from my desk can you remember what else
was in the cubby
pencils erasers some peanut butter cups
a photo of my bird
but nothing else was taken
it was clive cunningham how do you know
he's the only one allergic to peanuts
wow thanks abe whenever we watched
movies as a family
i would always spot the bad guy who's
the bald man
[Music]
and guess the ending in the second act
she poisoned his drink
seth barry used to be nice but now he's
mean i need you to find out what
happened
somebody keeps wearing my bicycle
without asking permission
i found this in the park i need to know
what it is
i noticed some blood on my dad's car i
want you to find out what happened
are you sure
i saw that constable cleary was in the
yard again you wanted to catch me up on
some of the latest cases
oh that's so cute son we want you to
know how impressed
we are i have never seen a young person
take such initiative for the sake of
their community
i was 12 when someone finally chopped
down my tree house
the town raised enough money to set me
up with a real office
in the middle of mainstream the mayor's
daughter
gracie was my secretary i used to parent
soda pop
are you back mom's office oh hi daddy
he's in with principal irwin want me to
take a message somebody stole the cash
box from the school fundraiser
what was it for animal rescue
rory beans was bit by a dog last summer
someone's been sneaking up the clock
tower
changing the time smells like the red
shoe gang don't you have a boy on the
inside
not anymore he kept getting grounded
i was often in one of those situations
where you're looking for evidence in a
house
and then you hear the owner come home so
you have to hide
and it keeps seeming like they're going
to open the closet but they don't
and then you sneeze and give yourself
away
oh my god that's adorable bill come and
look at this
one day while taking a stroll it
suddenly occurred to me who had robbed
mr hepburn's candy store
i was awarded free ice cream for life
there you go abe thanks mr h
as a reward for all my hard work i was
invited to play drums for shark water
at the annual fall barbecue
sometimes i would lie awake all night
and wonder if i was the smartest person
in the world
oh my god i met this super cute boy the
breakfast for the s weekend
you're always meeting cute boys it's
driving me up the wall
see you later see you later
it's been nearly two weeks since the
abduction of fourteen-year-old gracie
gulliver
and the local anxiety continues to mount
i can't believe
she comes to my store all the time
things like this aren't supposed to
happen here
the mayor and his wife released this
emotional statement on tuesday
hello
oh hi i was just wondering
how much longer do you think it'll take
you to find gracie
i'm not sure my mom told me not to tell
you this but we're all really counting
on you
i know you can do it
[Music]
[Music]
possible cleary still hasn't called me
back
try and get some sleep sweetheart you
have to stop torturing yourself
she knows you're thinking about her
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you